the mine at all a popular figure in
Greek mythology a half bull half human
that resides in the labyrinth of Crete
but how did the minor Thor come to exist
and what is a story behind the beast -
the future king of Crete was embroiled
in a fierce competition of his brothers
as to who would rule the island in his
desperation - pray to Poseidon the god
of the sea to send him a snow-white bull
as a sign for no one would dare go
against the word of the gods in return -
was to sacrifice the Beast in order to
honor Poseidon for his gift however -
had grown attached I could not do such a
thing
instead he sacrificed one of his own in
the hopes that Poseidon would not notice
the difference this only served to anger
Poseidon as punishment he made - his
wife passive a fool in love the Beast
that he could not come to kill pacify
the love of the animal only group as
each day passed she had Daedalus the
master craftsman but a hollow wooden cow
which she then climbed inside of in
order to mate of the Beast and thus the
minor toll was borne pacify tried her
best to nurse the monstrous offspring
but as it grew older it became more
ferocious and uncontrollable its only
form of sustenance came from that of
devouring humans
unable to contain the beast and in fear
for his kingdom king - traveled to the
Oracle of Delphi to seek advice King -
was told to build a labyrinth underneath
his palace in order to contain the mine
at all
upon his return King - are stateless and
his son Icarus to build a labyrinth
capable of holding the Beast King - his
only son travelled to Athens to take
part in Athenian games there are some
who believe he was killed during the
games as the Athenians were jealous of
his skill and prowess and there are
others who believe that King at jeaious
of Athens ordered the boy to kill the
minor tour and as a result of his
failure was killed by his half-brother
upon hearing the news that he had just
lost his only male heir - was furious
and waged war with Athens upon
consulting the Oracle King Aegeus of
Athens gave in to the demands of King -
every year Athens would send seven boys
and seven girls to be sacrificed at a
minor tour as punishment for the death
of his son during the third year of
tribute King Aegeus his son Theseus
volunteered to go to Crete and to kill
the Minotaur himself thus ending the
plague brought upon Athens
Theseus promised his father that on
return he would hoist white sails if he
was successful and the crew would fly
black sails if he had been killed upon
arrival both of - his daughters Ariadne
and Phaedra fell deeply in love of
Theseus unable to deal with the idea
that Theseus could be killed by her
half-brother Ariadne went to Daedalus
and begged and pleaded for him to tell
her how to escape the labyrinth before
entering the labyrinth Ariadne hand
Theseus a ball of string for him to find
his way back after he had killed the
Minotaur
after searching for some time Decius
found the beast and awoke him from his
slumber eventually he managed to
overpower the Beast
and stab him in his throat fatally
wounding him in some variations of the
tale
Theseus killed the Beast of his bare
hands
once the beasts had been slain
Theseus used the ball of string given to
him to find his way out of the labyrinth
and returned to Phaedra and Ariadne they
soon left and set sail for Athens as
they journey back to Athens
Theseus abandons Ariadne and the island
of Naxos as it was always his intention
to marry Phaedra Ariadne is eventually
found by Dionysus the god of wine and
the to marry close to Athens and with
his new wife Phaedra
Theseus could not contain his joy
however it was because of this
absent-mindedness that he forgot to
change his sails from black to white
upon arriving King Aegis sees the black
sails raised on his son ship overcome
with grief he leaps off the cliff
killing himself Theseus is now set to
become the new Athenian King
and that concludes the tale of the miner
tour if you've enjoyed this video then
please go ahead and leave it a like
because that helps a lot if you'd like
to discuss the story or even suggest a
topic that I can talk about in a future
video then please go ahead and leave it
in the comments and I'll get back to you
if you feel like I've earned your
subscription then hit that subscribe
button and stay tuned for the next video